well I think when you're offered a job
it is some you've got to be very careful
when you're in the interview especially
if you're working with someone new
because you are going to be spending an
incredible amount of time with them and
it's it can be a very intense period
specifically post-production so if
you've got any feeling that you're not
going to get on with this person or
you're not in any way like-minded I
would recommend running away because
otherwise you've got a year oh hell if
that's not the case and during that
period you you realize that you're both
like-minded I normally find when I'm
meeting someone you are about to work
with someone you as you talk about
movies not necessarily the movie you're
going to work on but the movies you love
and without exception you know as you
listen to the director talk and they
listen to me talking if you're all kind
of on the same page with what you love
and what you like and what turns you on
about movies you know you're gonna get
on and if they're talking about films
that you can't stand you know you're not
so it's a good idea to be convinced that
you're in sync I want a better for one
of a better term with the way everyone's
looking at the project because I think
being an editor you're being cast as an
editor as you would cast a composer or
cast a cinematographer or in fact cast
an actor
it's you've got to fit in with the
overall picture otherwise those working
parts are not going to come together
a typical day in the cutting room for me
would be to watch rushes first thing in
the morning at around 9:30
my assistant usually starts at 6:30 so
that her name is Charlotte she can have
rushes for me right away i watch rushes
then I start assembling each scene and I
normally have to send the assembled
scenes to the director the same day so
my assemblies are very tightly cut
they've got soundtrack they've got sound
design
if there are any green screens I usually
compose them first so that my assistant
can finesse them I layer all the the
compositions I want all the bits and
pieces if it's a visual effect I add all
the elements so I could have up to ten
elements sometimes and because it's so
time-consuming
my assistant Charlotte does them and
then we send it off at the end of the
day for the director once I've watched
the rushes
I usually either call or text the
director to make them know that
everything's okay or if I have issues if
I want pickup shots or if they're
missing some of the subtext we discuss
it I think the thing with Susana that I
responded so well - I think she
appreciated is she wants everyone she
works with to bring whatever they can to
it she doesn't want to tell people what
to do she has very strong ideas and she
has a strong of authorial voice but she
wants you to just bring your personality
and your thing to it so I would assemble
and I spend a lot of time working hard
on assemblies and some editors like to
leave things rough and directors like
that Susana sort of wanted more not
finished products because it's never
gonna be finished but to really work on
everything and present things to her
that you thought this is what I think it
should be and she responded really well
to that so in a way working together she
was more focused on overall story and
overall structure and pace and actual
some technicalities of cutting the scene
the scene works I think as always it was
structure it was how a lot of the
stories were quite similar so how do you
make one person's story distinct from
the other one and that was the hot yeah
that was the hardest thing we work we
work a lot with index cards and there
were quite a few iterations of scenes
going on and characters that would come
in and then we would drop them yeah
that's that was probably the biggest
challenge and and also getting some of
the scenes down it's just as always
choosing which which parts you actually
want and I think it's very very easy I
mean it's what I call kind of sort of
poverty porn or distress porn like you
there's a really delicate balance
between being sensationalist and showing
a necessary amount of distress and
suffering that you get your message
across and I mean Louise really good at
that anyway because tonally with humor
he does amazing things with humor and
and breaks the ice and so for me it's
bringing it's bringing Louise
sensibility and my sense building the
direct sensibility on that altogether
and we have we do have a lot of
discussions about tone and always that
joke too much or and Louise quite aware
of that so yeah it's really great
collaborating with him she's why I've
done a lot I think when I first read
Chris's draft of Dunkirk it was scary
and exhilarating because normally he's a
heavily dialogue oriented scriptwriter
so you were always pushing the narrative
forward through dialogue whereas Dunkirk
was very very little exposition and it
was going to be a very visual film and
and the visual storytelling you know is
what was going to make this film worth
watching and of course you layer on top
of that the intersecting timelines which
Chris loves to play with time you get
this kind of war movie like no other
which is not reliant on you know carnage
and blood in the camera and all that
kind of thing it's relying on a level of
suspense that Chris said early that he
wanted to maintain he wanted to run this
feeling of your heart beating away right
from the first frame of image you're
starting to get tense and that first
gunshot you're tense pretty well all the
way through the movie and it was very
experimental when I read the script I
was thinking this could be a hundred
million dollar art movie and probably be
the end of all of us but thankfully it
wasn't baby driver actually was was
unique actually and it was possibly the
culmination of the way Edgar and I had
started working potentially a little bit
on the
shoots for a film Edgar did fees back
called Scott Pilgrim vs. the world where
I came on set and did some onset editing
for the additional photography that
developed a little bit more on the
world's end where he asked me to be on
set for all the action pieces so we can
put them together as they were being
shot in problem-solve but then with baby
driver because there was such an
incredible mix of music and live action
and drama and dialogue and stunts and
everything Edgar said you know what it
would probably be really good if you
were on set the entire time and in
actual fact that's actually what
happened I mean not with Santa the fact
that I had actually worked with Edgar on
and off for five years prior to that
helping him prep stuff even before we
kind of shot a frame I'd had a very long
gestation period with him in helping to
sort of put sound sequences together and
then table reads with sound effects and
music and a lot of prep and animatics I
mean even but you know just before we
started shooting baby driver we actually
had the whole film as an animatic and we
could show all the HIDs head of
departments in Atlanta the entire film
as basically drawn or storyboard which
was a fantastic thing to have for
reference if they're shooting two
cameras on some of the shows I've done
we've had maybe 80 hours of material I
think three girls might be 40 for one
hour
it was quite high because Philippa
shutter did a really beautiful
documentary style where the camera was
always moving we didn't use conventional
wide shots and close-ups reversed shots
so we have more footage longer takes in
the script it was beautifully written
first of all by Nicole Taylor and she
had woven some of the stories together
but because when we were cutting we
discovered some different information in
particular in Episode two we had to
remodel episode two but we did it
together all of us together and Nicole
came to the cutting room and we we
played things out and there was some
scenes that we had to create from
material if we discovered for example
that Sarah Rowbotham heard something on
the radio and that scene was never shot
I used footage from episodes two and
she's in the car and we'll were together
with trees download at the original
radio interview
so it was it was actually finding the
structure was very organic and it was
very collaborative all of us were on the
same page and we met the real people who
were involved and that also kept the
illness of responsibility on us to do
our best to tell the story in as
truthful and as inconsiderate away as
possible
although the crown is considered
television for for Netflix it's every
episode is treated like a feature film
so for me I have the collaboration with
the director Steven Daldry who is
amazing and since he comes from film he
insists on keeping me on to the end of
the mix so as an editor I'm able to
follow the film through to the very end
well I edited episodes 8 & 9 8 deals
with the with the Kennedys coming to
Buckingham Palace and episode 9 is about
the Gordon Stone episode with Prince
Phillip and that Prince Charles and
their experiences they're now both
episodes were completely different in
tone so I had the pleasure of editing a
comedy and then a very serious
heartbreaking drama so for me I had the
best of both worlds
in episode 9 although it was brilliantly
written I did restructure a lot of it
because there were times when we cut
away from one boy too early and
emotionally we wanted to stay with that
one boy whether it was Charles or Philip
I also had to find interesting
transitions and so visually it was it
was a challenge to to discover where we
should switch over what shots would
complement each other
for example after Prince Philip bullies
the Queen and insists that Charles stay
at Gordon stone we added one shot of
Philip going into the hallway and
looking out the window and then there's
just a flicker of remorse and he looks
down and script wise I was meant
to cut to young Phillip on the obstacle
course but I chose to move up a shot of
Charles young Charles looking in the
trophy cabinet at young Phillip and so
this juxtaposition of older Phillip
cutting to young Charles looking at his
father as a young boy in the trophy
cabinet with the trophy was emotionally
very connecting of all three characters
in the show so I try to apply that
throughout the whole show there were
hours of interviews so you had basically
the all the interviews with the main
people all his band members from the New
York a day from his black star album and
from the album before at Tony Visconti
of course the producer and we had a very
very good archive researcher who found a
lot of material for us to use and of
course they shot on that one they shot
all the songs with the bands or key
songs with the bands and so it was
pretty amazing actually hearing the band
that played on the record actually
playing the track and when they gave us
David Bowie's team vocals we were able
to sort of construct a version of the
track with the band playing live and put
his vocals on there which is kind of
unique and was pretty extraordinary
actually pretty extraordinary hearing
him saying Lazarus with no music very
very poignant actually I think the
biggest challenge editing this film was
just one of keeping it accessible to the
audience and keeping the audience with
us and not making it so complicated that
people just gave up and and got confused
with what they were looking at and just
keeping the tension level up and and
keeping the exact point of the emotional
release when the little ships showed up
with Kenneth Branagh that was a really
critical moment because if we moved it
slightly earlier or later in the
timeline you didn't get the emotional
rush that you did when it was in its
exact position and we tested that
numerous times because we were trying to
pull it forward and trying to push it
back and it just
and its natural place that was a big
challenge and I think just you know
keeping true to the reality of the
situation and not letting you know not
letting it be inundated with CG
enhancements was the other challenge of
you know not doing shots with 10,000
little ships coming at you because
that's not what happened
so you know trying to keep it much more
real and I think the audience know that
I think inherently when you watch your
film and you see a shot and you just
know it's been loaded you kind of well I
do anyway I sort of go yeah right I
think the key skills to be a good editor
is to listen be collaborative follow
your instincts watch the material see
what feels truthful to you and if it
feels truthful to you it will feel
truthful to the audience you have to be
very diplomatic you have to negotiate
notes and be an ally for the director
but also not exclude the producers or
the exec producers so sometimes there's
a balancing act that we have to do but
in general all of us producers writers
exec producers all of us we want the
best for the film so it's actually a
very collaborative thing I think you
need a good memory because sometimes
when all the notes come in
you might remember something that you'd
seen in the material that would actually
solve a note that is given in a
different way a different solution maybe
to the note given but most notes that
are given they come from a good place
and you have to address whatever that
concern is so I think patience good
memory diplomatic skills and follow your
instinct people sort of say when they
see stuff that I've done that they they
go I can see your style so maybe you do
have a style whether you kind of like it
or not it's hard to know because it is
such an instinctive thing I guess if
you're a musician or an artist or
anything more sort of traditionally
creative you'd have a style and maybe
that's better to have that rather than
do sort of whatever you're told
so maybe yeah I think I probably do have
standards not
tell me what it is
[Music]